[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's a
Prof hello
Walter hello
Martin is this the type of thing that
happening to us well it looks
interesting well let's let's see what it
where it takes us yeah maybe calm seas
and just smooth Tran Waters smoo s you
feel like Smooth Sailing I need we need
to pray I think so our heavenly father
thank you for all the wonderful truths
that you've put in the word help us to
delve deep into them and discover all
the wonderful gems that you've put there
and to place it into perspective that we
can learn from it we ask this in Jesus
name amen
amen we've titled this one inacted
Parables uh we want to talk about the
specific
one and just to create the
backdrop I think we can look at a few
enacted parables in the Bible just
generally about the Bible mod have
you ever read a book like this one no
it's impossible to read something like
this because you you read a story now
and you read it in three weeks again and
it's totally different and it's a
different story okay now if you take a
penny horrible of yourself and you read
it then you're done with it for the next
50 years right because when you read it
it's going to be exactly the same as it
was last time MH you might
forget what it said but uh eventually
it'll be exactly the same but this one
is is new every morning yeah and the
same verse that you read yesterday as
you say is not going to say the same
thing tomorrow because the context will
be
different so you can read the Bible like
a historic story just go through it and
then put it on your shelf and say okay
done with that you can read the Bible as
a prophetic book mhm and then you know
people always ask how what percentage of
the Bible is prophecy the whole Bible
every sentence is prophecy MH how much
is history also the whole one how much
is salvational yeah the old one that's
true so everything is 100% prophecy so
if you can't find prophecy in every
sentence then you need to read it again
yeah and you can decide how you want to
read your Bible you can read it as I say
as a story book you can read it as a
prophecy book and as a as a
puzzle you know people like games that
are like quests and something like that
well there's no better quest game than
that trying to figure out where what
fits and how it fits and then you can
read it by looking at inacted
parables Jesus taught in Parables yes so
that they could understand and he
predicts that he's going to preach in
Parables so was he only going to start
when he came and not have Parables
before no no he had many many parables
the whole Bible it's his nature to speak
to you like that to to awaken something
in your thinking patterns that might be
slumbering yeah whereas if you told the
person
directly they would uh uh get annoyed or
rejected or whatever but if they look at
a parable they might Ponder what can
this mean yeah maybe the description of
for to to maybe just explain what does
it mean to say that it's in inacted
Parable well it's like a like a theater
portrayal of an
event but there's a there's a hidden
meaning in the Parable so it's a real
life
situation but it's showing towards
something greater yes all right
sometimes the parable is an instruction
from God to perform a certain Act of
theater as a as a
example and sometimes Which is far more
interesting is when it is written into
the life of a person yeah yeah because
that person still has free will he has
free will but he is enacting a story
yeah and the life so let's take Daniel
if you read the story of Daniel that
could just be a historic story oh okay
Daniel and and you know Kids Daniel in
the Lion's Den is there a greater
reality in that story or let's take
David and
Goliath is it just David in Goliath or
is there a greater reality in it and how
does it all fit together so let's give a
few examples of these kinds of stories
in the Bible and then we want to discuss
a specific one right yes we're working
towards something yes all right so in
acted Parables you have the story of
Abraham and Isaac let's just start
there now there are many many aspects
about these particular individuals
Abraham Isaac Hosea Daniel
Ezekiel all of them they not only are
real life people mhm they don't only
have real
lives but they're also enact Parables
yes so and sometimes these Parables as
we have said are written into their very
lives and are not just instructions of a
performance yes so it's not a direct
instruction God telling them this is
what how it should be and then this is
the lesson for the people all right if
you take Abraham and his life his real
life story he had to come out of
Earth and he had to separate from his
family he had to go to another country
Tre where he was a sjer and never had
anything yeah he went down to Egypt he
came back from Egypt all of those
stories are
actually examples of a greater reality
but they really happened in his life
life yeah and we have to follow the same
path correct we have to come out of our
of the calans we have to separate from
Babylon yes we have to break with the
traditions of our families we have to
become soers and strangers in Land Of
Promise in other words this Earth has
been promised to those that are redeemed
but you're just going to be a soer there
and you're not going to have an easy
time and every now and then we have a
tendency to run to
Egypt
yeah and uh face our problems by trying
to concoct stories and lies to get out
of the situations that we are in so
written in his life are realities that
are uh for everybody that ever lives yes
right but he also had to enact Parables
yes so that's his life story and then
there was an in in fact his entire life
story is an enacted Parable yeah but
then he had to perform a specific one
yes and Isaac of course was Paramount in
that story and then he gets the
instruction go and sacrifice
Isaac now that must have totally
stressed him out right of course and he
goes to a particular
Mountain which is actually the same
Mountain on which the temple would be
built and that portion on which there
would be a
crucifixion he had to take the wood and
he had to lay it onto the back back of
Isaac they had to go up the
mount and Isaac said here's the wood but
where's the
sacrifice and then he had to sacrifice
Isaac and at the very last
moment God Will Supply the sacrifice but
he already sacrificed Isaac mentally
mentally you're absolutely right he had
to go through that process
uh have you in your life sacrificed
Isaac yes there has been portions or
I've definitely had to sacrifice Isaac
because the Son of God had to die for us
all right and they had to die because of
your transgressions MH uh
did Adam have to
sacrifice an animal yes so everybody has
to make that sacrifice every single
person uh does something have to die in
you I mean if Abraham had to think about
it and he had to say okay I'm going to
sacrifice
Isaac did something die in him yeah it's
like his whole life was just over right
there was the son of
promise and it was just over he the
turmoil he must have gone through was
tremendous yeah and it's a type it's a
type it also shows how much trust and
faith he had in God yes that even though
he had to go through this loss inside he
knew that God would Supply so the King
James says
God himself will supply the
sacrifice the new translation says for
himself which is of course a totally
ridiculous translation because God
doesn't need a sacrifice for himself he
has never sinned he will supply it
himself so there was a type and an acted
Parable showing the greater
reality of the Plan of
Salvation and it was
enacted absolutely
perfectly and they both came down again
from the hill so they would a
resurrection yeah so his faith was so
challenged and he knew that there must
be a resurrection at some stage because
why would God say that this is the son
of promise and that all nations will be
blessed through him and he's dead yeah
wouldn't make any sense wouldn't make
any sense so there's a beautiful enacted
Parable in uh the case of Abraham and
Isaac
now if we look at
Hosea that's an interesting enacted
Parable yes that's not uh such a comely
example yes it's a it's a rather sad
example so poor
Hosea has to marry
GMA and GMA is not exactly a lady of
repute
no
and she runs off
occasionally and then he has to go and
purchase her yeah and he he he gives his
whole self to get her back and it's such
an interesting story poor hoseah the
prophet that's an enacted parable of the
relationship between God and his people
yeah the woman is the church
right and so it shows how we go astray
and how God God goes after us it tells
us something about the character of God
how
he how he gives of himself yeah and he
must have been in love with her yeah it
must have been because it's interesting
if you say it like this
because he she actually belonged to him
but he still had to purchase her back
yes because she was always going astray
it's the same with God we belong to him
but he had to sacrifice himself just to
get us back okay so there's
another uh enacted Parable we'll talk a
little bit more about some of the
details in a
moment all right let's look at a few
others Daniel and his
friends there is a an actual event that
takes place in the life of these people
so this is not an instruction from God
you go and do this now and this will be
the consequences and then you go and do
that this and the other as in this case
of of Abraham and
Isaac but Daniel's whole
life is an inacted
Parable it is a type of the life that
God's people will be confronted with
yeah and the circumstances around it are
exactly what God's people will be
exposed to mhm so Martin will you be
thrown into a literal Lion's Den proba
you can yes maybe did the early
Christians get thrown into literal lion
dens yes was the outcome always as
favorable as in the case of Daniel no
unfortunately not but they like Daniel's
friends in the oven said though he slay
me and they were Martyrs and yet will I
trust him but the greater reality is
even if the Lions should have eaten him
there would have been salvation yes but
they had to become a greater story yeah
now what was the
lifestyle that Daniel had the whole life
of Daniel if you study Daniel then you
will come to the
conclusion that Daniel to me is very
depressing the reason why is depressing
because he doesn't put the put the foot
wrong all the other characters in The
Bible let be it Abraham or Isaac or
Jacob or any one of them they always are
blundering along making mistakes but
Daniel is immaculate yeah he didn't make
a a fault but then he admits that he is
not Immaculate because in his prayer he
says we we we have sinned we have we
have sinned so why is he portrayed as
Immaculate because that is what God
actually wants his bride to be all right
that's where we have to strive for
Daniel never never said I've arrived no
no never but this is where we have to go
yeah and if you think about the sadness
of it before he arrives in Bas Babylon
he is
emasculated which is a rather sad state
of
Affairs so the Uno is the one who has to
take care of
them and basically in this world we
suffer spiritual
emasculation our our our manhood is
actually taken away and we are put into
the slavery of
sin in a sense we are
captives of another Power
and here he is in
Babylon but he has a a
certain
character and one of the first things he
does is he confronts what's on the
table and why because they have to get
clear Minds ah all right so Daniel has
to have a clear mind and he remembers
what Solomon wrote when you sit at the
king's table put a knife to your throat
lest you partake of his
Delicacies so here is an example are
there any that join him in this example
yes only three three it's rather sad eh
out of all the captives that were taken
yeah probably 800 or so yes there were
three that's not a very good statistic
no and when it came to the
confrontations that they had where their
faith was
tested we don't hear anything about the
others no we only hear about Daniel and
his friends and for the rest of the
story you only hear of them all right
were the others ever thrown to the Lions
no were they thrown into fiery furnaces
no were
they uh disobedient when it came to
bowing down no
so they actually had a good
life so they they didn't have these
confrontations probably people said says
you're right you fanatic if you go to
the Lion's Den right exactly oh okay
look at these Fanatics they they being
thrown into a fiery furnace serves them
right I guess there must be some that
speak like that because it happens in
real life so here is a a
typological life which has a typological
lifestyle and we'll come to some of the
other little details later so all of the
stories that we read about Daniel and
his friends are enacted real life
Parables and stories applicable to us
right y okay so that's another example
in the
Bible then we have the story of Ezekiel
now Ezekiel was a prophet during the
Exile and he was a contemporary of
Jeremiah and the interesting thing is
God tells him to enact a couple of
Parables and if you'll read his story
there are realities associated with it
and perhaps we can look at one or two of
them Ezekiel
4 thou also son of man take thee a tile
and lay it before thee and portray upon
it the city even
Jerusalem and lay Siege against it and
build a fort against it and cast a mount
against it set the camp also against it
and set battering rams against it around
about moreover take thou unto the
an iron pan and set it for a wall of
iron between thee and the city so poor
Ezekiel like a little boy has to go and
build a maano set
there and he has to do all of these
things and then he gets an instruction
which would totally freak me
out lie th also upon thy left side and
lay the iniquity of the House of Israel
upon it according to the number of the
days that thou shalt lie upon it Thou
shalt bear their iniquity for I have
laid upon the the years of their
iniquity according to the number of the
days 390 days so shalt thou bear the
iniquity of the House of Israel so every
day he had to go for a whole year and
more go and build his
little city in image and the pan and he
had to lie on his side and stare yeah
they must have thought is this guy
nuts and then he gets the
instruction so do it again and go now
lie on your other
side now they must have looked at this
and they thought what's going on with
this Pro with this prophet and then he
has this instruction to go and bake an
Ezekiel Bread it's a very healthy bread
by the way if you take all of these
components wheat barley in verse 9 beans
lentils Millet FES and Baker bread the
FES is spelt
mhm have you eaten spout bread yes
that's all I bake these days it's
amazing grain makes a very light bread
and uh also very digestible very
digestible yes I love spelt bread and uh
we get our the whole kernels we make our
own flour and we bake a spelt bread with
different combinations you can put a
little bit of all of these other
interesting things in it but that's
another
story and then he gets an exact
instruction as to how much he may
eat and then he gets an even worse
instruction which tells him how to bake
it yeah that he has to
take human excrement to bake it and this
is where he loses then I said in verse
14 now Lord God behold my soul has not
been polluted I can't do this now this
is not too much I mean I've been lying
on my side here I've been building
little mountains and sitting with pans
and now I've got to bake bread with
human
droppings God says to him okay you can
take cow dong
it's not much better but it's probably a
little bit
better and then he gets this instruction
of how much he can eat and it's it's a
starvation diet
yeah it's a starvation diet Now what's
the meaning of all of this it's a it's
to create a hunger for the word through
starving
them starving them not literally but
starving them for the word yeah isn't
that something that will happen in the
last days in the last days and it did
happen Through the Ages and it will
definitely happen in the last days as
well well we can see
that we're already experiencing and
people will be running to and fro
looking for the word and they will not
find it yeah it's it's an enacted
Parable it's actually a very beautiful
story well another one comes to mind
Jeremiah mhm who has to take a loin
cloth uh in modern terminology your
underpants then he has to go to the
Euphrates that's where Babylon is right
that's it and he has to go and hide it
in the CFT of a rock
buried and then after many days months
he gets the instruction go and fetch
your
underpants go and get your loin cloth
and or he goes and gets his loin cloth
and it's totally
destroyed and he says you know this Lo
cloth is useless it's
totally perished and rotten I can't I
can't wear this
thing and basically the Lord tells him
that this loin cloth is Israel Israel
that went into Babylon and was polluted
polluted and rotten and
rotten and he says but this is this is
how I feel now you know when you when
you put on a loin cloth or an
Underpants that's about as intimate that
you can become with a a piece of
clothing right so what was God trying to
say say this is my relationship with you
it's a very intimate and a very personal
relationship and look what you did you
went to Babylon and you got yourself all
polluted and now you expect me to wear
you again it's like the story of of
Hosea and G polluted and take her back
so here's a portrayal in
Hosea of of what it looks like in terms
of the marriage relationship here's a
story enacted by Jeremiah which shows
that uh how intimate that relationship
is and how terrible it must be for the
one who has to wear that filthy garment
what kind of picture of God do you get
from these inacted Parable I think a lot
of
caring because even though it seems
harsh it enacts how he feels about us
yes and it's a very personal God and
it's a very intimate God it's not just
some God up there that is never
intimately associated with these
creatures and the other example that we
have on the screen here is John the
Baptist so John the Baptist is there an
enacted Parable in the life of John the
Baptist oh for definitely he's the
Forerunner to make clear the way for the
Son of God all right and he's called the
Elijah or the second Elijah but there's
reference to another Elijah that would
come just before the great and terrible
day of the Lord exactly so if you study
the life of John the Baptist you have to
study the attributes of the final
Elijah and what he's supposed to be like
now
again when you look at his story is
there like in the case of Daniel a
specific lifestyle definitely once again
his lifestyle was showing the same as
Daniel to have clear Minds to be able to
accept the truth all right and his diet
was Locust and wild
honey of course that was St John's bread
which is the Carib bean and not living
locusts and honey is a plant
product it's not eaten by the bees it
goes into a different chamber and is
converted into honey it's not
pre-digested
food so it is
plant-based so John the Baptist had a
plant-based diet did Daniel have a
plant-based diet yes yes give me puls
which is plants
vegetables and beans and everything that
goes with it so there's a specific
Lifestyle the son of man came eating and
drinking and John the Baptist came not
eating and drinking he was very
particular was he
particular yeah of course he was he said
I'm not going to I'm not going to do
this please please this is just too much
can can we modify it all right it was an
issue of addressing the defilement of
the people so here John the Baptist was
different you know in the world when you
look at movies that have John the
Baptist in it he looks like a
wild yeah moronic idiot yeah with this
hair like this
and they take that coat of woven um
camel skin and make it as if he's a as
if he's wearing the skin yeah which is
not the case it was a finely woven
garment made from camel's
hair so John the Baptist is
peculiar he doesn't eat like the rest of
them it doesn't dress like the rest of
them and he has a very particular
message makes straight the way of the
Lord he addresses certain issues even
with
Kings don't break God's
Commandments in his case he was
referring to the seventh
commandment which is referred to in
Hosea yeah it's a no adulter breaking
the seventh commandment is break a
personal
relationship so if you break the
Commandments of God then you are not in
a covenant relationship with God yeah so
he calls people back to a covenant
relationship with God it's like a
marriage it's like a marriage so the
story of John the Baptist his message
and everything that pertains to it is a
type of the message that has to go to
the world at the end of time so those
are examples of enacted parables in the
Bible now you can read your Bible also
by looking at the names and studying the
names that's a totally new way of
reading the Bible let's look at some of
these stories that we looked at and see
if we can glean anything out of the
names and uh the Plan of Salvation is
written in names but that's important to
know the Plan of Salvation is written in
names not the names is salvational no no
of course not the Plan of Salvation you
have to look at the story behind The
Story So if you take Abraham we
discussed him for example his name was
Abraham and that means High father yeah
and then his name was changed to
Abraham father of a multitude
all right so Abraham
represents those that are saved through
the righteousness of
Christ and he lived his own
life and then he had to come out
of and then he had to leave his father's
house and then he had to become a
sourer and he had to become the father
of a multitude
now when you were living your own life
partying going to the Rave culture being
a a DJ making a lot of Senseless
noise moving and swaying you you're
probably also the father of a multitude
but not a very good multitude right no
then it's you have to get out of her so
anybody that lives the life that Abraham
lived in other words who separates
himself from that which is evil and
separates yourself to the
Lord now there's an interesting verse in
the Bible where it says even the E the
the
stranger that separates himself to the
Lord that keeps the
Sabbath yeah so the Sabbath is a sign
that you have separated yourself to the
Lord to the Lord yeah so all of these
stories in the Bible are fascinating so
Abraham's name
Abraham High father his name is changed
to Abraham father of a
multitude so he becomes the precursor as
it were to anybody who receives the Plan
of Salvation in Abraham's seed you all
become part of the spiritual Israel
correct so the same applies to to
Abraham's wife
Sarah we read in Genesis 17:15 and God
said unto Abraham as for SAR thy wife
Thou shalt not call her name SAR but
Sarah shall her name be there's a subtle
change of name which is a depiction of a
a character
change so Matthew P's commentary says s
signifies my lady or for my princes can
you see there's an element of Self in
there uh he's the high father and this
is his wife but now they have to become
examples of the Plan of
Salvation and this confines her Dominion
to one family but
Sarah Sarah signifies either a lady or
princess simply and absolutely without
restriction in other words she's going
to become the mother of this multitude
of this
multitude so you have gone from this
from a selfish life to a non-selfish
life and the Bible also says more are
the children of the baren woman these
women were all baren yeah God supplied
and even if she'd never had a child more
would be the children of the baren woman
than of the non-b woman because what
kind of what kind of offspring are they
producing those that will be HS to
Salvation so here written in the names
you have actually
enactments yeah you have you can you can
read The Plan of
Salvation what's the other one that we
spoke about we spoke about
Hosea what does Hosea mean it means
deliverer Now isn't he depicting God
yeah isn't he depicting Jesus yes isn't
he running after his estranged wife yeah
and GMA means
completion so in the
end this estranged wife will be brought
to completion that's it it will be
brought back so the beginning of the
word of the Lord hoseah
1:2 by Hosea and the Lord said to Hosea
go take unto thee a wife of
whoredoms and children of whoredoms for
the land has committed great whoredom
departing from the Lord so he went and
took GMA the daughter of diim which
conceived and be him a
son now we discussed that as an enacted
Parable yeah let's look at the names
mhm so the names of his children were
jezel
Luma and
loami those were the names of his
children two boys and a
girl so let's have a look what Maya's
commentary says about these
names God gathers the outcast the story
of hosah is a pathetic
one he felt impressed that it was his
duty to take his wife one whose earlier
life had been
unchaste from this marriage resulted
three children the names of whom are
terribly
significant they are as follows so the
first one means God will
scatter the second one means not an
object of
favor and the other one's name means
once my people but not so now would you
name your children
that I wouldn't um choose it but if the
Lord wants to have a enacted Parable he
probably would have been so somehow God
must have impressed him that these are
the names of his children that come out
of this relationship of whoredom yeah
here's the history of many a soul in
spite of all God's Tender Love We may
wand from him in the path of sin
the chapter closes with brighter prostin
naations in part these latter verses
were fulfilled by the return from
Babylon and they will be fulfilled in
literal fullness someday probably sooner
than we have been want to
suppose it is good to lay the emphasis
on in the place there how often we are
taken back to the very circumstances in
which we appear to have have failed most
conspicuously in order that they may
receive the crowning blessing of our
life hoseah 1:10 leave God to vindicate
you he will bring you from the land of
the enemy and extort this confession
from the mouth of your critics and
foes it's not a bad commentary
no sort of sums it up right that's it
and um once again we can see that all
the enactments were a story that God
wants to show us how it pertains to his
bride okay so have we established that
the Bible is full of enacted Parables
yeah no for sure right we've established
that have we established that uh you can
read these Parables even in the names of
the people
yep and sometimes the names are really
strange and sometimes God didn't even
directly say this is what you should
name your children yes but in them
naming their children it's still an
enacted Parable correct let's just make
sure let's get one or two more examples
just for
completeness the story of Ruth and
Naomi in Ruth chapter 1 now it came to
pass in the days when the judges rulle
that there was a famine in the land the
famine is always a death a a lack of
spirituality and a certain man of
Bethlehem Judah went to San in the
country of Moab he and his wife and his
two sons you know whenever there's a
death we always want to go to some other
religious experience so or he went to
Moab should he have gone there no not at
all probably not right and the name of
the man was
El which actually means my God is
king and the name of his wife Naomi
which means
Pleasant so there is a lot of good in
those names and the name of his two sons
Malon mean
sickly and kilon wasting wasting
away now as a result of going to
Moab you have a terrible situation your
Offspring is sickly and wasting away
yeah there an interesting enacted
Parable in the
names and uh so they were actually
ephes of bethlem Judah so they were
God's people but they were sickly and
wasting away The Offspring
and they came into the country of Moab
and continued there and Al nai's husband
died and she was left and her two
sons and they took them wives of the
women of Moab did God permit that in his
word no God did not permit this at all
all right so this is what they did they
took wives of the women of Moab there
are consequences when you do that mhm
they might be converted but they might
not right no and there's always
consequences even though they get
converted there's always consequences
all right so the name of the one was
orpa which means neck or for so they
have an interesting typology okay and
her name means neck or for the nape of
your neck you know when you say I will
take you by the Scruff of your hair
you take you by the back and the this
neck was tending back towards
Moab and the name of the other one was
Ruth which means
friend that's interesting H so this one
was a a friend friend of what a friend
of the truth perhaps friend of God your
God shall be my God and your people
shall be my people and the only way to
achieve this is to get out of Moab and
to go back to where you belong right
yeah and they dwelt there about 10 years
and Maron and kilan died also both of
them that's pretty explicit mhm if you
stay there you're going to die yeah
because you have become sickly and
you're wasting
away and the woman was left of her two
sons and her husband just a little story
there there about how this
works Daniel and his friends we spoke
about that now among these were of the
children of Judah
Daniel which means judge of God or God
is my judge now he's a type of the end
time people what they must be like and
they will be a people of
judgment uh isn't there a message in
Revelation which says the time of is
that yes judgement has come has come and
then you have
hananiah God has favored or been
gracious and then you have
mishel who is what God
is there will be a mik that stands up
who is what God is and asarah God has
helped so these are all
very uh faithful names and and they have
a story they have a story to tell for
the end time people who will be living
in the time of the judgment and God will
favor these people and He will be
gracious to them and they must develop
characters of the one who is like Mikel
who is like God
is and God will help them yeah isn't
that nice it's beautiful it's old plan
the whole Plan of Salvation written in
the names of the
people unto whom the prince of the
gave names for he gave unto Daniel the
name
belasa baale predicts the king or baale
will protect are they trying to change
their religion yes and to ananiah of
shadra command all belonging to
Aku and to
mishel it says servant of Aku or servant
of the Moon God and to asarah
Abednego servant of Neo or servant of
light now who's the light bearer Lucifer
Lucifer so is there a
tendency in Babylon to change your
religion from God is the one who judges
God is the one that favors and treats
you
graciously and becoming like God in
character to accepting baale as your
king to protect you becoming involved in
Moon worship and the moon worship often
has a female characteristic yeah so the
moon can be as a male deity or is a
female
deity and then you become a servant of
the
lightbearer that happens when you get
stuck there that's happens when you're
stuck in Babylon right is there a Plan
of Salvation written in there yeah for
sure do you have to resist it we have to
go back to the original names all right
how do you resist it only by the help of
God of Jesus okay does that mean you
have to be very particular in how you
conduct yourself for sure how you obey
God even in terms of Lifestyle yeah
that's why we've got enacted Parables
examples all right was that was our
introduction
[Laughter]
ah if this is the way God writes his
Plan of
Salvation in the Old
Testament do you think he might ignore
this kind of thing in the New Testament
no for sure not he will not did Jesus
teach many things in Parables I think he
only taught in Parables all right so his
whole his whole way of thinking is
Parables if he
wrote enacted Parables into the lives of
people could he write enacted Parables
into the lives of New Testament people
yes that's his style all right so let's
look at a particular one which is very
interesting and uh if people want more
details I did do a series Once called
from Creed to Malta mhm but let's look
at it in terms of an enacted Parable and
let's go through it
carefully bracing the winds that's
actually our subtitle there bracing the
winds enacted
Parables we want to talk about the story
in the closing chapters of Acts acts 27
and 28 mhm and see if there's an enacted
Parable yeah that applicable to us all
right now if this was if this was the
story of the early
church which had the former
reain would there be a parallel with the
latter rain definitely so everything has
an application it's like type and
antitype all right you have the enacted
type but it's in a
bigger um way applicable to the
antitype they had to be born again
right and uh the last people also have
to be born again in fact anybody who
ever accepts The Plan of Salvation has
to be born
again but the last message of warning
will be of a universal nature with a
universal scope with a mighty
conflict and so let's look at Paul's
last journey couldn't this be the last
journey of God's people yes why don't
you read it and then we discuss it let's
go through it verse by verse 100% And we
start at acts
27:1 and when it was determined that we
should sail into Italy they delivered
Paul and certain other prisoners unto
one named Julius a centurion of
augustus's band all right carry on and
entering into a ship of
adium we launched meaning to sail to the
coast of Asia one aristarchus a
Macedonian of thessalonica being with us
and the next day we touched at sidon and
Julius courteously intreated Paul and
gave him Liberty to go onto his friends
to refresh himself and when we had
launched from then we sailed under
Cyprus because the winds were
contrary all right so here we have the
story Paul is being sent to
Rome and he gives us a little bit of
background there were prisoners on board
yeah so
prisoners people that are captive into
in something yes so there were prisoners
on board and there was a
centurion of augustus's band so he was
not normal Centurion he was closely
associated with the ruler himself yeah
with kingley with with the kingley
band and we have the names of certain
people that were with him and probably
Luke was on this ship as well
M and here they sailed and from the
outset when they launched yeah the winds
were contrary the winds were contrary
against them so when this ship starts
sailing the winds are country this is
the final voyage the final
ship on its way to the Final Destination
okay and that final destination is a
confrontation with Rome yeah that's very
important to realize and the winds are
contrary yeah not going to be easy well
let's have a look at our our backdrop
over here bracing the wind so you're
bracing yourself against the wind yes
and winds are an an example of strife
and War and hardship okay now the windw
country is not quite so bad yet it'll
probably get worse right it's a little
bit irritating actually yes so you're
struggling along that's basically what
it is you're struggling along and when
we had sailed Over the Sea of CIA and
pamilia we came to Myra a city of lisia
okay so this progress he's moving along
getting there he's explaining the
journey and there the Centurion found a
ship of Alexandria sailing into Italy
and he put us
therein okay so now there's a change and
you're now on a ship from Alexandria and
off you go now Alexandria is a very
interesting City the largest library in
the ancient world was there and it burnt
down the whole thing burnt down to the
ground wasn't gnosticism very entrenched
in there there was so much occultism in
those writings and so much gnosticism in
those writings that uh it boggles the
mind but that's another story whether we
should go that deeply I don't know but
and when we had sailed slowly many days
and scares were come over against
nidus the wi wind not suffering us we
sailed under Creed over against salmon
all right so they sailed slowly the
progress is not very rapid right it
doesn't look as if you're going to be
super successful in this journey yeah
and also doesn't the it's uh we're just
carrying on and the wind the wind
doesn't allow you to do anything that
you really want to do and hardly passing
it came unto a place which is called the
fair Havens n where unto was the city of
laia now when much time was spent and
when sailing was now dangerous because
the fast was now already passed Paul
admonished them and said unto them sir I
perceive that this Voyage will be with
hurt and much damage not only of the
lading and ship but also of Our Lives
nevertheless the Centurion believed the
master and the owner of the ship more
than those things which were spoken by
Paul okay so Paul is speaking and Paul
of course represents the word of God
yeah and he says s i perceive that this
Voyage will be with hurt and much
damage will the The Voyage of God's
people and his church in the last days
be with hurt and much damage
definitely not only of the
lading that which is on the ship and the
ship but also of Our
Lives now they didn't believe him no
they rather believed the other people
correct is there a parallel there yes
yeah all right we'll believe anything of
somebody else but um what the church and
what the leaders and what our go God
showed us oh and what the spirit of
Prophecy is telling us now will rather
go with something else we'll rather go
the other route okay let's
continue and because the Haven was not
commodious to Winter in the more part
advised to depart then also if by any
means they might attain to phice and
there to Winter which is an Haven of
creed and lith toward the southwest and
Northwest all right let's just stop
there I like the wording here and people
you know struggle with sometimes with
the King James wording but it's it's so
rich yeah and if you don't know a word
look it up that's it you just study it
come up step up to the plate if you st
if you struggle reading it just read
more read more so it was not
commodious I like that word a commode is
a sofa where you lie on and relax it was
not commodious
and so the greater part or the more most
of the people said I don't want to be
here it's not comfortable we want to go
to that place where it's let's go to
this other place and it's much more
comfortable there and let's go there do
we have a tendency to do that oh and I
wanted to ask is it very commodious to
work in a Ministry these days uh it's
not very commodious and if you think you
want to go to a better place you're
going to end up worse
worse okay so off they go and what
happens and when the south wind blew
softly supposing that they had obtained
their purpose loosing things they sailed
close by
Creed but not long after there arose
against it a tempestuous wind called
urum I love that verse it's one of my
favorite verses in the Bible you think
think you're going to go to a
comfortable place I've now I've accepted
the Lord this is going to be great this
place is not
commodious you just want smooth sailing
we're off we're going to another place
and then there is this tempestuous
wind which is not a slight wind it is a
roaring
G and you end up in this mess and you
say what happened yeah
but you weren't listening to what Paul
said you were trying to find an easier
path and you ended up in a worse
situation okay such TR such truth and
when the ship was caught and could not
bear up in the wind will let her drive
okay so now you can't even steer the
boat anymore you're in such trouble you
you're just being taken wherever off you
go and running under a certain Island
which is called claer we had much work
to come by the
boat much work now it's hard work now
you're beginning to labor and the sweat
is pouring down and you don't even have
time to eat no you're stressing yourself
into a coma yeah okay which when they
had taken up they used helps under ging
the ship okay so now the ship is in
danger mhm so now they're going to help
they're going to underg good the ship
they're going to make sure it doesn't
fall apart yeah so that's putting a belt
or something around it and tou strapping
down things and making sure this thing
stays together do you think God's people
will be going through that situation I
think we're already there we're starting
to see we have to hold on to the truths
and start getting it close and old okay
and fearing lest they should fall into
the quick Sands strike sail and so w
driven so are there more dangers around
than just tempestuous winds and stormy
seas yeah there quick
Sands what happens to you in quick sand
you just down you go and there's nothing
you can do so let's get out of here and
that can also be quick sand of thought
that you just get caught up in the
depression let's get out of there let's
strike the sails let's get out of here
and we being exceedingly tossed with a
tempest the next day they lightened the
ship okay so
Martin is it possible that you're
carrying a lot of baggage that you might
not
need how about throwing it overboard
getting rid of everything that is a
danger to the ship so you're in trouble
now and you are exceedingly tossed with
a tempest you're probably seasick by
now so let's lighten the ship and and
then and the third day we cast out with
our own hands the tackling of the ship
is this not Insanity yeah you're getting
rid of that that is supposed to say to
help you and get this thing just fixed
and ready for this so are you now
reliant on faith alone that's it because
you've gotten rid of everything that you
thought was
necessary so we're sitting in the final
Church yes heading in this storm
to a final destination a final
destination and now we're getting rid of
everything that we cling on to that we
rely on ourselves and we only rely on
God okay and when neither son nor stars
in many days appeared and no small
Tempest lay on us all hope that we
should be saved was then taken away okay
now we're in big trouble there's no sun
and no star it's dark
dark is this world in a dark place yes
is it getting darker and darker no sun
and I like the euphemisms of the Bible
no small Tempest so it's it was roaring
it was
chaos and all hope that we should be
saved was then taken away don't people
today despair oh what's the suicide rate
like I I think it's escalated it's
it's actually scary it's scary right
there's no hope depression um anxiety no
hope and then these people go to cop 28
and spin a lot of lies and tell you
that's where the problem lies the
problem doesn't lie there the problem
lies elsewhere exactly they go and spit
fear and this small no small Tempest is
actually huge and they just try and put
the blame all on you again and are they
listening to Paul no no no not at all
they're on their way to something
commodious but they're actually in a
storm where they will own nothing and be
happy Okay carry on but after long
abstinence Paul stood forth in the midst
of them and said sir you should have
hearkened unto me and not have loosed
from Creed and to have gained this harm
and loss and let's just stop there
there's another
opportunity Paul has an opportunity to
preach and he says you should have
listened but you don't want to listen
you think it's going to be commodious
it's not going to be commodious and the
problem is not where you think it lies
the problem is much deeper and you
haven't taken any food no what kind of
food could we be speaking about
spiritually the Bible you're not
listening to that you're looking at
climate change that's it you didn't take
the spirit of Prophecy this storm Martin
was as a consequence of climate
change 2,000 years ago never has there
been such a storm before climate change
that's it no spiritual declension that
was the problem and that is also the
problem today all right what was the
problem in Sodom and Gomorrah the same
they had much Leisure Time yes
commodious time they were commodious
okay and now I exalt you to be of good
cheer for there shall be no loss of any
man's life among you but of the ship
okay so there's going to be an
accident for they stood by me this night
the angel of God whose I am and whom I
serve saying fear not Paul thou must be
brought before Caesar and lo God hath
given thee all them that sail with thee
whoa
this is
amazing enter the spirit of Prophecy
yeah huh exactly in the midst of the
storm enter the spirit of Prophecy and
those that listen to it what will happen
they will be safe along with the rest
that go with Paul everybody that goes
with Paul will be saved everybody that
accepts the message yeah will be saved
what an amazing Pro promise read here
wherefore s be of good cheer for I
believe God that it shall be even as it
was told me oh he believes God yeah not
cop 28 no and he comes with a message
from God that the angel showed him so
the storm is as a consequence or as a
means to bring you to your
senses but you could say the storm is as
a consequence of climate change that
wouldn't bring you to your senses that
would just lead to Greater idiocy it
will just take once again that you are
not to blame you're just self it's
somebody else to blame again okay how be
it we must be cast Upon A Certain Island
but when the 14th night was come as we
were driven up and down in Adria about
midnight the Shipman deemed that they
drew near to some country so we're going
to have a collision with an island yeah
now the island is not mentioned here
yet but it is about midnight that this
will
happen Martin when we reach the midnight
of this world's history there's going to
be be a
collision we at the 11th hour past I'm
sure so the Gospel Ship is going to have
a collision okay let's let's continue
and sounded and found it 20 fathoms and
when they had gone a little further they
sounded again and found it 15 fathoms
then fearing lest we should have fallen
upon rocks they cast four anchors out of
the stern and wished for the
day
Martin it's getting more and more
dangerous the storm is
Raging the water is getting shallower
we're going to
crash they put out four anchors yeah
they really don't want to crash right
and they're wishing for the day wishing
for week starting to look towards this
coming day oh I'm also aren't you
wishing for the day I canot tell you how
much I'm longing for that I'm wishing
for the day wow what's going to
happen and as the shipmen were about to
flee out of the ship whoa what were they
doing they wanted to get out this can't
be the right ship no I'm getting out
okay Carry On when they had led down the
boat into the Sea Under color as they
would have cast anchors out of the for
ship all right so here are people on the
ship who decide this is This ship's not
going to make it yeah I'm getting out of
here I'm putting down my a little
Lifeboat okay they've got four anchors
out at the back holding the ship pulling
at its back waves crashing from the back
so now they're pretending that they're
putting anchors out in the front as well
which is
useless and they want to actually get
into boats and get away from the ship
yes what is the what's Paul's
response Paul said to the Centurion and
to the soldiers except these abide in
the ship he cannot be
saved that's probably a very important
verse this enacted
Parable has has this verse in it if you
don't stay in the ship listen to what
Paul had to say listen to the spirit of
Prophecy that came over him uhhuh you
will be
lost now people get very angry when we
say that these
days let's rephrase it put
superglue on your backside and stay in
the ship yeah okay okay then the
soldiers cut off the ropes of the boat
and let her fall
off and while the day was coming on Paul
besought them all to take meat saying
this day is the 14th day that ye have
carried and continued fasting having
taken
nothing wherefore I pray you to take
some meat for this is for your health
for there shall not an hair fall from
the head of any of you okay well so here
they are they actually Cut the Ropes now
they know it's useless what they're
trying to do they've given up the idea
of getting off the boat so there's a
very specific meaning in all of
this and he says take some meat now meat
in the Old King James means food if it
was flesh then he would have said flesh
right and he keeps referring to the 14th
day
and then he says you have eaten nothing
they are spiritually starved that's it
take in the word yes don't be like the
foolish virgins go and study see where
we are in the Stream of time go and eat
the word of God and then what will
happen it will be for your health yes so
it's for your for your own benefit is
this only spiritual health or could
there even be physical health for sure
for the physical health as well so if
you have even the health message is here
and then what'll happen if you do that
not one hair will fall from the head of
any of you that's quite a promise I
Martin do you find this promise
elsewhere in the Bible as well oh many
many places many places and when he had
thus spoken he took bread and gave
thanks to God in the presence of them
all is he setting an example oh yes and
it's bringing us back to who's the bread
giver and when he had broken it he began
to eat then they were all of good cheer
and they also took some meat all right
so how important is the
example absolutely very important it's
actually getting the onm
mindedness has the storm Abit it no it's
still raging it's raging right but they
they they have good cheer they get it
they calm so in the midst of the storm
you can be calm yeah if mhm if if you
eat and
partake of the word of God okay let's
continue and we were all in the ship 23
score and6 souls and when they had eaten
enough they lightened the ship and cast
out the wheat into the sea but they took
the bread they ate it were filled and
now they're taking
wheat this was the cargo of the ship now
what does wheat stand for the bread of
life what are they doing with it casting
it out into the sea what does the sea
stand for multitudes and Nations and
tongues okay so now they are ready to do
what they were called to do this is a
typology irrespective of the fact that
there were non-believers on this ship it
is an enacted parable of what is
happening in the Gospel Ship and when it
was day they knew not the land but they
discovered a certain Creek with a Shore
into the which they were
minded if it were possible to thrust in
the ship they're still looking for a way
out they're not going to find it no and
it's still storm raging all right
they're trying to find an easy path to
land the ship softly it's not going to
happen okay and when they had taken up
the anchors they committed themselves
unto the sea and loosed the rudder bands
and hoisted up the main sail to the wind
and made toward the
shore now that's
amazing they've now decided that they're
going to pick up the anchors they're
going to Hoist the main sail and there's
a roaring tempestuous wind and they're
going to go for it and now they're going
to go go for this headon headon
collision and falling into a place where
two Seas met they ran the ship a ground
all right two seas meet it's an
interesting statement in the Bible now
could it be that the multitudes the
people the
nations are going to meet in this
particular place in other words two
mindsets are going to meet in this
particular place in this place where
this confrontation is going to and
there's going to be a clash yeah and the
four part stuck fast and remained
unmovable but the hind apart was broken
with the violence of the Waves so the
ship is actually beginning to break
apart but it's reached a certain very
important destination it is stuck fast
now in this moast that PA it's like uh
Lucifer saying to Gabriel whoa you're
not getting past me
Here's the final
confrontation now if uh
Gabriel couldn't hold him up who had to
come and help him Michael ah let's carry
on and the soldiers' counsel was to kill
the prisoners lest any of them should
swim out and Escape will there be a
death decree at the end for sure right
when this happens a few moments later
there will be a deathe so we can maybe
make itle clear this stuck fast of the
ship this confrontation is when the
Sunday law is in implemented okay but
the the death decree is not actually
carried out here yes so it'll only be
implemented later a little bit later
that's why they said it's time to give
the to kill but not they're talking
about it but it's not being implemented
okay but the Centurion willing to save
Paul kept them from their purpose so God
is
containing this final thing yeah and
commanded that they which could swim
should cast themselves into the sea and
get to the land and the rest some on
boards and some on broken pieces of the
ship and so it came to pass that they
escaped all safe to land all right so
they stayed on the
ship and now the ship is breaking apart
so there's a terrible shaking yeah but
they're still clinging to the boards of
the ship yes they haven't abandoned the
pieces of the ship they're still going
so this is the storm and now there is
this final
crash where two seas meet two mindsets
meet and two mindsets are going to clash
there's going to be a clash of Minds
yeah yeah isn't that interesting it is
interesting I don't know why we took
this
name
all right let's go to acts 28 and read
that this is now the very last event
that is portrayed in the book of Acts so
they're now on this island and now we
want to know what is the name of this
island yeah and when they were escaped
then they knew that the island was
called meita all right so now they know
where they are now that's the island of
Malta that's the seat of the military
arm of the Roman Catholic Church yes the
Knights of
Malta that's the Army yeah and if you
look at the emblems of the kings of the
world they all wear the emblems of the
Knights of Malta will there be a
confrontation with the religious and the
political world yes the and those
regalia is the Knights of Malta cross
yes the males cross so there will be a
mindset
confrontation and the confrontation is
between the gospel message and the
military religious power that will rule
at the end and it is depicted as the
island of
Malta and the people there are
barbarous barbarous that's a terrible
thing to say of the Knights of Malta
that they dressed so nicely in all their
regalia carry on and the barbarous
people showed us no little kindness for
they kindled a fire and received us
everyone because of the present rain and
because of the cold ah so here was
rain they were on land and here was an
abundance of rain so they kindled a fire
should we Kindle a fire during an
abundance of rain
we actually should start kindling the
fire now when there's also just rain
drops falling didn't what didn't
Jeremiah say when he said I will no
longer speak in this name ah but your
word was a fire in my heart and I could
not and here is an abundance of rain is
this the latter rain being poured out
when we have this
confrontation
with the forces of barbarism I believe
so all right and some of them are
showing you no little kindness yeah
that's very interesting so not
everybody that is there trapped in this
barbarous situation is averse to the
idea right no well that happen during
the latter rain definitely okay Carry On
And when Paul had gathered a bundle of
sticks and laid them on the fire there
came a viper out of the Heat and
fastened on his hand and when The
Barbarians saw the venomous Beast hang
on his hand they said among themselves
no doubt this man is a murderer whom
though he hath escaped the sea yet
Vengeance suffered not to live all right
now the confrontation here or this
story is The Barbarians looking at
what's happening to
Paul Now The Barbarians who are The
Barbarians
the European nations the the 10 horns
were called The
Barbarians so here you have Echoes of
Daniel coming in yeah yeah and uh one of
the reasons why there were called
barbarians According to some is because
of their language which was different
and they couldn't understand it and they
said it sounded like
B so they called it barbarians that's
just one of the stories all right so so
here you have the
barbarians which in modern times would
be associated with the 10
horns and they're looking at this and a
snake attaches itself and what happens
and he shook off the Beast Into the Fire
and found no harm all right but they
also said no doubt this is a this man is
a murderer so they're they're very
skeptical of
him but then they see that nothing
happens to him now there's a promise in
the Bible yeah that uh you will tread on
scorpions and serpents will bite you and
you will drink poison and it will not
harm you now that has not been very
prominently visible throughout the
Christian era but it's a promise for the
latter rign that's it when this
confrontation will be in its fierceness
state okay so it was also a promise for
the for the former Reign so now in the
latter Reign this will happen this is
the outpouring of the spirit of God yeah
and when this happens these people
sang that wow nothing happened to him
how be it they looked when he should
have swollen or fallen down dead
suddenly but after they had looked a
great while and saw no harm come to him
they changed their minds and said that
he was a God all right so now they're
looking at him with different eyes in
the same quarters were possessions of
the chief man of the island whose name
was
pus who received us and lodged us three
days
courteously and it came to pass that the
father of puus lay sick of a fever and
of a bloody flux to whom Paul entered in
and prayed and laid his hands on him and
healed him so when this was done others
also which had diseases in the island
came and were healed who also honored us
with many honors and when we departed
they laid us with such things as were
necessary okay Martin so under this
power of this latter reign will there be
signs and wonders that follow the
Believers will there be healing there
will be healing and I believe that this
also shows to the people that will come
out of that barbarous or that Babylonian
State yes and after 3 months we departed
in a ship of Alexandria which had
wintered in the aisle whose sign was
cter and Pollock and landing at Syracuse
we tarried there three days and from
then we fetched a compass and came to
Rum and after one day the south wind
blew and we came the next day to
puoli where we found Brethren and were
desire to T with them seven days and so
he went toward Rome okay so there's this
confrontation and
eventually in
Rome there will be a captivity for a
while and there will be a final
outcome You Know M we don't have to
discuss the rest of it now the final
events in Paul's life and all of these
things the story of the final voyage and
the conflict that took place there is
now basically completed that's it up
until the confront confrontation at the
island of
Malta so that is an enacted Parable or
it is a possible enacted Parable let's
not be dogmatic in L we get into trouble
no because the other ones is already you
can see the result this is still
unfolding this is still unfolding all
right you know Martin let's just wrap it
up with a few statements from Spirit of
Prophecy because people should have
listened to Paul maybe they should pay a
little bit of attention to these things
as well yeah this one comes from the
great
controversy as the storm approaches a
large class who have professed faith in
the third Angel's message but have not
been Sanctified through obedience to the
truth abandon their position and join
the ranks of the opposition I think some
will climb off the ship yeah there will
be a
shaking by uniting with the world and
partaking of its Spirit they have come
to view matters in nearly the same light
and when the test is brought they are
prepared to choose the easy popular side
they want a commodious life
men of talent and pleasing address who
once rejoiced in the truth employ their
powers to deceive and mislead Souls they
become the most bitter enemies of their
former Brethren when Sabbath keepers are
brought before the courts to answer to
their faith these apostates are the most
efficient agents of Satan to
misrepresent and accuse them and by
false reports and insinuations to stir
up the rulers against
you can find much of this in this last
portion that we didn't read now of
chapter 28 just read what happened there
how there was confrontation and some
believed and some believed not yeah
that's what happens the end Happ and
that's what happens when you leave the
ship that's what happens so M don't
leave the ship
yeah I had an impressive dream last
night I thought that you were on a
strong vessel sailing on very Rough
Waters sometimes the waves beat over the
top and you were drenched with water you
said I shall get off this vessel is
going
down remember the words of Paul unless
you stay in the ship you cannot be saved
yeah are we saved by the ship no no you
have to do some swimming and clinging to
a board as well you're not safe by the
ship the the saving was the faith the
faith saves you no said one who appeared
to be the captain this vessel sails into
the harbor she will never go down but
you answered I shall be washed overboard
as I am neither captain or mate who
cares I shall take my chances on that
vessel you see Yonder said the
captain I shall not let you go there for
I know that vessel will strike the Rocks
before she reaches the the harbor you
straightened yourself up and said with
your positiveness this vessel will
become a wreck I can see it just as
plain as can be the captain looked upon
you with piercing eyes and said firmly I
shall not permit you to lose your life
by taking that boat right we cannot take
this story and make it an absolute
parallel of that which we just read no
this is talking about the Gospel Ship
that you have to stay on that's it and
there was also a ship that you had to
stay on there was a final
confrontation but this one is the same
don't leave the ship this ship has got
the truth this ship has got everything
that you need correct don't go to other
ships and then try and throw stones at
this ship correct the Timbers of her
framework are worm eaten don't go and
join the Babylonian vessel
and she's a deceptive craft if you had
more
knowledge you could discern between the
spus and the genuine the holy and that
appointed to utter run but if you had
more knowledge and
discernment knowledge comes by reading
and eating the word of God yes
discernment comes by obedient to all the
principles even those that Daniel was a
type of yes so that your mind can become
clear you can have discernment correct
so the church may appear as about to
fall but it does not fall it remains
while the sinners in Zion will be sifted
out the cha separated from the precious
wheat this is a terrible ordeal but
nevertheless it must take
place stay on the
ship the ship is on it it way to a final
confrontation yes there will be a clash
of
minds and you are either with the one
side or with the other and that is I
believe the
story in an enacted Parable in the book
of Acts and if that be so or not I
believe there are tremendous lessons and
we should
study so that we can be amongst those
virgins that will enter into the wedding
Feast amen let's
stand Heavenly Father what a tremendous
story what beautiful lessons are hidden
in your word help us to appreciate it
more and more and help us Lord to cast
out the wheat into the sea before it is
too late it's my prayer in Jesus name
amen
[Music]